what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing our discussions on
the dark multiverse we pick up with the
Wild Hunt and this is actually really
really good because one of the questions
that I've seen from you guys and one of
the questions I've been wondering myself
is how does Barbato sees the multiverse
that's the overarching goal of Barbados
when it comes to like everything that
goes on in Dark Knight's medaled it
Barbados you have like the whole world
Forge and everything that's really was
designed to kind of create worlds create
universes and then send those out into
the multiverse but those universes that
were deemed to be too corrupt or too
evil or quote-unquote discarded but the
idea was that with Barbados you know a
kind of abandoning his post and then
seeking to effectively conquer the
multiverse the question was how would he
pull it off because he tried it once
before right like we talked about that
in Dark Knight's metal before in the
previous videos he was defeated by
Hawkman and then that led Hawkman to
really ask the question what's the
nature of this info metal which cinimon
his whole journey when it comes to the
multiverse the issue was how do they
take it I mean there is like a heart of
the multiverse there's no place that you
can go where you can effectively kind of
synthesize a poison of sorts that would
spread throughout the Otherworld but the
question is how are they going to pull
it off is it really just Barbados going
there and then just kind of like
shouting really loud and then just
dispersing his power across the cosmos
you know is that really how that whole
thing works well the cool thing about
this is that this answers the question
this really kind of gives us an
explanation of how it is the multiverse
will effectively fall now one thing that
we do here at least how we initially
pick up is really light it's kind of
strange with the origin of Detective
champion with regards to this origin it
seems to me that DC is grabbing a
combination of a couple of different
things the first is DC Comics presents
number 85 I think back in 1981 and then
the days of vengeance storyline now the
DC Comics DC Comics presents stories
actually think it's 35 now that I think
about I don't think it's 85 but anyway
the DC Comics presents story is actually
pre-crisis that's before crisis on
Infinite Earths so we don't really have
to run with that ah days of vengeance
was basically a story that was written
by DC as a lead-up to Infinite Crisis
remember after crisis on Infinite Earths
DC still had a lot of continuity errors
and so because of that a lot of the
stories like zero hour crisis and time
and things like that what is on to kind
of wrap up those stories or the very
least provide new origins or updated
origins for characters it didn't really
have them after the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths and for the character of
detective chimp that was one of those
things and for the most part this origin
seems to fall closely in law and it even
goes all the way back to like Rex the
wonder dog back in 1952 I think was
before with John Broome and carmine
infantino but there was a whole idea the
basically detective chimp is just like a
chimpanzee that was taken by a guy named
Fred Thorpe in this instance it seems
like he's kind of stuck in a shantytown
or at the very least some sort of a
carnival attraction but the idea is that
somewhere along the line you ended up
having Fred Thorpe who was basically
killed and there was no real
understanding as to why instead Bobo
really is what his name is we're just
kind of there as an attraction and he
was simply just a simian he was just a
chimp there was really nothing special
about him but following the death of
Fred Thorpe and the idea that he was you
effectively left the cage unlocked and
gave Bobo a chance to escape he
ultimately came into contact with rucks
the wonder dog now again this really
goes back to 1952 and that's why I say
DC's grabbing all kinds of different
things all kinds of different aspects
from over the course of the publication
history of detective chimp back with Rex
the wonder dog in 1952 this was really
one of those things we've talked about
before where DC was kind of focusing
more on like science fiction as opposed
to traditional superhero stories and for
the most part Rex the wonder dog was
actually really popular like he ran for
like 46 issues or something like that it
was a huge deal my people loved his
character but effectively what is up
happening is that Detective chimp is
taken to the Fountain of Youth which
basically grants him eternal youth as
well as the ability to communicate with
all form of animals that are out there
and this of course leads him on a quest
to basically you know figure out who it
was that murdered Fred Thorpe which
ultimately led to the incarceration of
those guys who were executed and one was
killed in prison but this kind of set
detective chimp on the path of becoming
a detective now one thing to bear in
mind about us Kara the reason why you
really haven't seen him a whole lot in
BC rebirth is because for the most part
when it comes to detective chimp and the
various magical creatures he's kind of
intertwined in the whole like vertigo
side of things so like Trigon and like
you know a Hellblazer and like the
spectre and things like that
detective chip is kind of like that
other side that whole magical side that
we've talked about before that doesn't
really cross over all that often with
the main superhero lineup of DC and so
what we end up doing is we basically end
up finding out a lot of this is taking
place on Blackhawk Island now remember
Blackhawk Island was the residence of
Lady Black Hawk essentially the
girlfriend of Hawkman and the idea was
that somewhere along the line you ended
up having again Hawkman going on this
quest and then you ended up having his
girl basically staying behind and trying
to figure out everything that was going
on hot girl you know for
a better word uh she was girl trying to
figure out everything that was happening
now where her journey led her alongside
like Wonder Woman taking off to like the
rock of eternity trying to figure out
what was going on going to the heart of
the multiverse what this does is it
basically says there are still survivors
here there are still beings who are kind
of floating around and one of these guys
is Professor Mauro
now Professor Mauro is the creator of
Red Tornado and Red Tornado is basically
the vision before the vision in Marvel
Comics so he has like all these really
cool abilities of different things like
that but it's one of those examples
where DC kind of created the standard
and then Marvel basically took it copied
it borrowed it whatever phrase you want
to use depending on how much you like or
dislike Marvel but the fact remains when
it comes to this whole scenario because
of the fact that the events of Dark
Knights and metal have meant that
reality is effectively breaking down
inside the main DC Universe what it
means is that this is having a wide
array of different effects in some
instances there's a physical change in
reality itself in other instances when
it comes to characters like detective
chimp his intelligence is effectively
starting to go away where he's basically
reverting back into a simian again so
it's just one of those things that kind
of feeds into the collapse of the
universe so to speak the problem with
this is that what they're also doing is
they're basically trying to get in touch
with something called the Ultima Thule
now the oath of a Thule we've talked
about before and that was really part of
Grant Morrison's Multiversity when it
came to the whole Multiversity line of
stories and we have a video on this that
you're welcome to check out so if we
won't go super in-depth into this but
when it came to Multiversity the idea
was a grant Morrison wrote Final Crisis
and we're Infinite Crisis brought the
multiverse back Final Crisis made the
heroes aware of it and so what Grant
Morrison wanted to do with the post
Final Crisis landscape was basically
tells stories of the multiverse and it
was a way for him to just kind of
continue writing for DC and do it in a
way that didn't really impact the main
DC Universe he could just kind of tell
these crazy zombie stories and some of
them were actually really really really
really good but the whole idea is that
the Ultima Thule is a vessel that's used
to travel from one universe to the other
figures remember in DC universes are
separated by harmonic frequencies that's
not like the flash you know kind of
jumps from one universe to another is
that he basically vibrates at the
frequency of another universe so if you
were to sit down at a piano and you were
to hit one of the keys that sound would
be like the main DC universe and if you
hit another key that sound might be you
know the injustice universe and if you
hit another key that sound might be like
the DC Cinematic Universe
you know and as long as you can vibrate
at that frequency at the sound of that
note you can travel to that universe
again this is really interesting in
terms of how it works but it can be a
little confusing if you're relatively
new to it now in between all these
different universes is what's called the
bleed it gets kind of crazy too gets
kind of wild I've always likened it to
like blood cells in the sense that you
have like red blood cells that float
around the human body and the red blood
cells are just different universes the
blood that carries the red blood cells
is the believ that's basically the space
in between and that's how you travel
here you can usually jump into the bleed
and then go throughout the bleed and
then travel to a particular universe and
then vibrate at the right frequency and
go into that universe that's what the
Ultima Thule does but what they're
looking for is the House of heroes and
the House of Heroes is where the
multiversal Justice League resides that
remember we covered that both as part of
Multiversity as well as the whole
lead-up to like Superman reborn this
idea that there is kind of a Justice
League that exists out there that's
composed of various forms of the
superheroes that we've seen from all
throughout the multiverse a female
version of Aquaman you have the
President of the United States on one
universe who's also Superman there's a
lot of these cool themes that go on with
those different groups but the idea I
remember the idea of flash and cyborg
wants to travel into the multiverse oh
really alongside Raven was to travel
into the multiverse and find help now
this was kind of DC teasing the idea
that maybe there's superheroes who were
trapped out there in the multiverse or
at the very least just bringing back
those Multiversity concepts but what we
end up finding out here is that in
addition to them basically traveling to
these other universes they're also being
tracked by the forces of Barbados and
this is cool because what Barbados is
forces are doing are firing these
various missiles at the Ultima Thule now
I want you to keep in mind because
that's gonna be very very important
that's gonna be a major thing when we
get later on down the line towards the
end of this story but traveling into the
multiverse what isn't happening is that
because they're effectively under attack
is one of these things where it's like
okay so like we got to get out of here
as fast as possible and they basically
end up showing up in a universe or I
guess on an earth where everything kind
of exists in the realms of like pirates
and things like that where you have like
pirate Batman and the other pirate
Justice League and if it things along
those lines but it is cool and it is
interesting because this brings into
sharp relief the nature of Raven with
Raven basically being the daughter of
trigons being the daughter of a demon
her powers are vast and they're extreme
and it is really cool because where you
end up having Dawnbreaker Batman who
shows up basically you know once they
start to board the
and they start attacking everybody what
is up happening is that Raven actually
seizes control of them and that's cool
and I mean look at this that's what's so
beast about this you know she's like my
dad's a demon make your little
constructs and we'll see what happens
because you do not scare a daughter of
hell and that's what that's see that's
why people love Raven because Ravens one
of those characters were if you go back
and you read her comics she's like kind
of like you know emo and she kind of
mopes around all the time and she sat
but like if there's anybody you want in
your corner in a fight its Raven like
she's hardcore and it's it's so cool
because it's one of these things that
takes the dark knights by surprise but
they don't initially realize what's
going on they're kind of shocked by the
whole thing like how is this girl able
to you know seize control of my
constructs the other half of this is the
nature of how it is the dark knights
were able to transition from you know
into the bleed and and basically chase
this group from one universe to the next
what they've done is they basically
empowered their ship using a miniature
universe that hasn't really grown into
its infancy yet and what they've been
doing is using a massive amount of power
to keep this universe contained to keep
it small so it can be used as an energy
source if this power were to be released
you know if this control were to be
destroyed more or less the universe
would just start growing rapidly you
know and just start forming life and
different things like that and it is
kind of interesting because what is up
happening here is that where you have
like Barry Allen who's basically trying
to find this universe and essentially
destroy it once he locates it uses
SuperSpeed gets around the Merciless a
lot of these guys he's met by the
arrival of Red Death but this is cool
because Red Death shows up a second too
late like a split second too late and
Barry destroys this universe and what it
means is that Red Death is basically
blasted with all this energy of a
positive universe and it kind of shifts
as polarity for lack of a better word
and so instead of Red Death basically
being an evil version of like Batman who
became the flash instead the Red Death
becomes a good version of Barry Allen
with the Batman persona cast off who
becomes the reverse-flash so it's
awesome it's so cool because I'll be
honest with you guys he looks amazing
a golden version of Red Death you cannot
tell me with a straight face that does
not look awesome like that looks so
Beast I do I'm I want to see Barry Allen
in that you know I want to see God speed
in that outfit that's how I want to see
God speed it looks so awesome and it
looks so cool but what this means is
that this version of Barry I guess this
this you know Red Death is really like a
good
it's kind of shifted him to becoming a
positive being now again that's because
the evil Batman persona was was sort of
cast off and that's the important thing
to bear in mind here these dark nights
they're basically Bruce Wayne or a
version of Bruce Wayne death succumb to
evil when it came to red death he was
two beings he was Barry Allen who was
merged with Batman when Batman used
Barry Allen and entered the Speed Force
kind of used Barry Allen as a key to
Gemma to the Speed Force and merged them
together into a singular being with
Bruce Wayne being the dominant
personality with that Bruce Wayne
essence kind of being obliterated by all
the positive energy that's there what it
means is that all you have left is the
flash now this kind of begs the question
is this an answer to how it is you can
destroy The Dark Knight and destroy
Barbados it is but it isn't this was a
singular universe a baby universe that
was used to basically destroy a Batman
persona to kind of wipe it away by
exposing it to all this positive energy
is entirely possible DC could use that
but the problem you run into you is that
it sort of brings in the idea that you'd
have to like destroy everything you have
to obliterate the multiverse in order to
destroy Barbados and then bring the
multiverse back and even then it seems
like there'd be no guarantee the
multiverse would return the way it did
before or that Marv Beto's wouldn't
return the way he did before so again it
is pretty ambiguous I mean this is part
of this I imagine is kind of like the
Grant Morrison aspect of the story
coming out as opposed to Scott Snyder or
Joshua Williamson and it is pretty
interesting and it does work the problem
with this is that in order to basically
destroy the sphere of expansion so to
speak of the Dark Knight's somebody has
to stay behind and basically allow this
baby universe to kind of grow and to
continue to expand and all that kind of
good stuff the issue with this is that
when the various members who were here
the actual flash Barry Allen a cyborg
when you have Raven where they all
basically depart after the quote unquote
defeat of the various members of the
Dark Knight's we end up finding out this
was all part of the plan the various
missiles that were being fired at this
group by the Dark Knights they contained
baby Dark universes and so what this
means is that the group has basically
traveled with the dark knights following
after them they traveled into the bleed
and all these dark universes are gonna
start spreading throughout the bleed and
impacting directly with the positive
multiverses so again it's crazy because
it kind of brings in this idea that like
this is how things have been going this
hold hunt and that's what is up
happening here back on Blackhawk Island
we end up picking up with detective
chimp and again where his mental
faculties are kind of a roading where
he's becoming less and less
smart with the last little tidbits of
you know knowledge that he has he
basically fries Red Tornado because his
idea is Red Tornado knows something
there's something that went on here that
led to him basically being captured by
the Black Hawks and when he was
originally released he started shouting
things like you opened the door you
opened the door you have to close the
door and then they shut him down
immediately because he started going
awry but he was never allowed to finish
his thought and so the idea of detective
chimp is let Red Tornado talk let him
tell us at the very least what he knows
and what's going on and so what this
does is it brings in the idea that all
of this has happened before and all of
this has happened again the whole idea
was that when you had the original
journey of Hawkman Carter Hall who went
on this journey to find out what was
going on within fettle that all this
basically took place that what you had
was Carter Hall learning the nature of
info metal learning about the dark
multiverse learning about the desire
Barbados to enter the positive
multiverse that there was a mission just
like the one they went on where was Red
Tornado and all these forces who went
into the bleed who were trying to find a
way to basically eliminate the sphere of
influence of Barbados who at the very
least you know figure out what was
happening the result was that his forces
were almost successful but Red Tornado
and company were able to close the door
off the issue is that Barry Allen and
them haven't done that they opened the
door for Barbados to come in and now
it's effectively too late there's really
no way just stop the collapse of
everything instead it's all basically
gonna come crashing down that this last
little vestige of hope they had of being
able to get out into the multiverse of
being able to find help to find people
who could basically take out Barbados
that it's all essentially gone that
there's nothing really there that once
they make it to the Hall of Heroes the
Hall of Heroes has been corrupted it's
been completely and totally taken over
and so it's it's wild because it
basically means there's nothing to help
them here it seems like there's no real
hope but what is up happening is that in
these last few minutes the group
basically discovers earth 51 I'm sorry
earth 53 and Earth that's not supposed
to exist and when they do we end up
having like the mind of detective Jim
that's basically kind of teleported away
it's essentially grabbed and then taken
to this new universe whereby everybody
is an ape you have like monkey Batman a
monkey Aquaman and monkey Superman is so
on and so forth and these guys are
effectively going to be one part of the
many groups who exist out there that are
essentially going to take on the force
of Barbados that seems to be the
conclusion that Scott Snyder is going in
that the heroes that resided in the Hall
of Heroes that multiversal Justice
League are likely
still alive and they'll likely be found
which means we'll probably start finding
other supermen from other universes I
really hope we see the return of Shazam
but it'll be kind of like this this
almost final crisis
esque scenario but we'll have like this
huge amalgamation of superheroes from
all across the multiverse who will show
up and try to take out barbados but that
just kind of seems to be the case but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain and make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob cork do you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]